okay to you sweet very cool very very
cool so we've incorporated some of the
local colors and brought them in to this
boutique hotel Cali how you feeling
amazed Room 205 is is an amazing amazing
room it's a New Mexico feel I don't know
is the bait but you don't mind do no no
no I think it's gorgeous
I did the balls are still beautiful and
yet we have all this color and it goes
so well with the area that we're in I've
got in color but there's something I've
taken away there are no more waivers for
your guests to sign is that good with
you Kelly
good it's awesome the front desk no
longer has waivers and the new rooms are
colorful they fit with exactly where we
are in this historic district I am very
proud to show people the new rooms I've
got one very small thing to show you you
ready they are this you love
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
that's what I call a pool yes remember
there was leaves and crap everywhere now
welcome to one of the hippest one of the
coolest pools anywhere in New Mexico
that is the oasis in the middle of the
day John is that hideous fence and
replaced it with new turf and pulled
furniture to die for beautiful it is it
is people will just want to come and
hang out here now man this is awesome
the pool absolutely beautiful never seen
anything like it
if we don't have pool parties now then
something's wrong this is your fantastic
Cabana area done is the stage if you
want to sing Kelly do it in the shower
[Laughter]
margarita Carlos I'll be serving a lot
of drinks out here I'm hoping the
business is gonna absolutely kick off
with his wonderful pool now that you
have a stunning outside area let me
introduce you to your new poolside menu
Wow so you start off with a lovely
refreshing tomato gazpacho goofily
marinated seasoned lovely with extra
virgin olive oil fish tacos as well I'm
gonna evolve our yes and delicious fruit
kabob well it's a great wonderful fresh
fruit mango orange lime coconut seasoned
where there's wonderful green local
chilies a taste of New Mexico not
Tuscany Kellie outstanding the tomato
gazpacho is
magnificent I'm very proud to cook this
food it makes sense and it goes with New
Mexico it I think it's excellent have a
good look at the menu get used to it
because we're gonna be pushing it
big-time
seen a minute this makeover is the
biggest I've done in any of the hotels I
visited there's over 150 thousand
dollars worth of upgrades and have never
been happier with the improvements it's
exactly what the guests need if I was
Kelly I'll be over the moon green
Chili's pecans everything that you
Mexico's about we have it on the menu
you know the guacamole we have the salsa
what I do with the five cases of
hamburger buns that I just brought in
[Music]
and even more hey what we want to spend
an hour putting things away every night
and then bring them out every morning
this is what Ramsay gave the hotel on
flavor flavor flavor flavor who do I
hire to do that this is a lot of work I
can't I can't I can't
oh my god there's things that I'm
concerned about the pools out standing
up it's scary to me because I've got a
pretty big job ahead of me now and the
linens major pain in the ass somebody
thinks that I'm gonna have to do that
right now you hunt you know I'm really
like freaking out over these and went on
what I'm gonna do is raise prices Kali
is a little overwhelmed right now I do
believe she likes the fact that it's
more New Mexican Jesus God Almighty but
how is Kali where is all my [ __ ] where's
all my [ __ ] what's that mean
the only other stuff that you took away
what's up the tapestries oh I know you
took down all the grapes yes it was
covering a pretty big hole in that wall
show me about no it's not what you're
worried about is a plastic bunch of
grapes to hide this where's somebody hit
it with a table we can get your cakes
back and you can stick plastic grapes
back on the wall let me show you
something for two seconds I want to show
something really important
just have a look at that out there how
gorgeous it's exactly what your guests
need and want let me show you something
Oh oh there it is I look at that amazes
them there and look at this pile of [ __ ]
in here and you'll start to create a
fuss forgetting that this hotel is about
the guests and you start putting the
team on edge because you want plastic
grapes here's what I'm going to do for
you
in 15 minutes I will clear all that
furniture okay
and I'll put it back in my van and this
[ __ ] here I'll put back in there